[Music]
tell me about this is on the card the
animal be very transparent about this
you performed Sweet Cheeks in Atlantic
City
oh yes that's the setup yeah well
pre-interview this guild they do the
show that Kevin Hart from the movie
theatres about last night I bet he used
to host this show and they loved him in
this thing but it was weird as this show
was supposed to start at midnight it
actually started somewhere closer to
like 2:00 in the morning that's two
doors late two hours late and it was
Atlantic City land city off the
boardwalk is not the glitz and glam of
the Taj Mahal
let me tell you it's really it's like
you know it's like toothless hooker
[__] will tell you and the idea the
show was you had this if you what he
said to if you survive ten minutes on
stage it was 300 bucks which was a hell
of a payday the spider-man's origin
story is that the crawl into the corner
a bunch of Macho Man Randy Savage is
screaming at us so it was hostile
environment but they did love keV and I
remember at this particular night they
didn't even like keV they weren't even
liking him very much
Wow so I go up there and right away just
start kissing ass I'm like what's up
blood people this is a really great show
I can't be up at this it's 3 o'clock in
the morning and everything and someone
goes stop kissing ass mother and I go
not Kissin ass but I totally am just you
know just trying to say it's a really
good show
and I hear a thud I look down this to me
through a dinner roll family dinner roll
of all things there's bread all over the
plate didn't hit me but I was like oh
you know what forget this man no like
I'm a man and I'm not gonna go to hell
again so you're not gonna throw shoot at
me I'm out of here good night everyone
screw it and I and as I walk off the
stage
keV grabs me cut him in front of stage
and he goes hey man he goes you guys
you're 10 min so if they're gonna
they're gonna mess with your money
they're not gonna pay you I go they got
a pain you die but kids they're why they
throw things at me he goes they're gonna
give you a problem and he goes if I calm
this crowd down will you come back up
yeah sure kid I'll come back up you calm
down a lot
and Kev goes on that stage and gave the
most moving Martin Luther King speech
this crowds that you can't just boo
people cuz they're white you got to give
him a chance to be funny Ike you know
you're acting like idiots and he's
giving a real like come on we're better
than that I mean I was in the back
putting up like a jet and you you ready
to have a good time tonight people for
real like yeah you ready for your next
comedian and they are yeah I'm even like
this is great and he goes give it a one
more time for big J and all the applause
stops and there's one like 300-pound
black what we're just going that edges
like that hostile I got Joker in prison
yes
yeah very good job I go on stage and I'm
so like green so at this point that - I
just go what's up look we have a really
great city same exact thing and out of
the darkness like a hundred chicken
wings just pelted me in the face and
mouth and all over and then I just
walked offstage know just walk right
back off stage they didn't pay me and I
drove home with a bloody lip from
particularly and chicken grease all over
my shiny white sneakers that I bought
ironically so black II would like me
more I don't care about 50 red sneakers
I thought black people did I thought it
would make me relate more if it makes me
about the show I did ten minutes later
when Kim went up on stage yelled at a
fat guy for throwing a chicken wing that
had meat on it still and then started
singing which was time appropriate
started singing I want my baby back ribs
stood up and threw a wing Kimball denies
to this day but we saw the guy from the
back of the room like and cab isn't
fooling I want my baby back baby back I
see this guy winding up this wing and
and as long as you know we're too far
away were like kid
[Music]
and that wind just waxing music y'all
show's over
no is it that was the end of that [__]
denies it to this day's day yeah Oh big
Jay oakerson everybody I call you the
full big Jay oakerson thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]